hi guys do you have these strange white
and red bumps
on your arms what is it exactly and how
do you get
rid of it that's what we're going to
talk about in this video
let's get to it
[Music]
just very quick if it's the first time
that you're on my channel welcome
i'm daniel and if you haven't subscribed
yet then please consider it
now what are these white and red bumps
here on your arm that looks kind of like
chicken skin some people might even
confuse it with
pimples or acne but that's not what it
is
it's actually called keratosis pilaris
now before we look at the treatment
there's a few facts that you need to
know about the condition
first to understand it better let's take
a look at them
kp keratosis pilaris does not just
appear
on the upper arms they can also appear
on your legs
your bum and sometimes on your cheeks
now kp is more common than you think it
usually starts at the age of around
10 11 and it might improve or even go
away by itself
in early adulthood 50 to 80 percent of
teenagers have it
and around forty percent of all adults
have it as well
now the reason why you get these bumps
on your arms
is all because of keratin it's basically
a protein that's found in your nails
hair and skin so the protein clogs up
your hair follicles and pores on your
arms and then
you get kp
it's in the family yes kp is genetic
and you get it from your family it
affects people of all ages
all races and both sexes although women
get it more than men
the weather can make it worse it gets
worse when your skin
is dry so it gets worse in winter when
it's cold and dry
and then in summer it gets better when
it's warmer and more humid
so how do you get rid of kp well there's
no magic cure for it
that will get rid of it 100 it's in your
genes from your family
but that being said there are a few
things that you can do
to improve the appearance of it and to
get less bumps
i personally used to have kp my kp
stand out a lot but as you can see it
looks a lot better now
so this is what you can do to improve it
when you take a shower and you wash
yourself don't use
cleansers or soap with fragrance in it
just use fragrance-free
cleansers that won't make your kp worse
i'll add some good options for you in
the video description down below
exfoliate you need a good exfoliant that
will
penetrate deep enough into your skin to
unclog
your pores you can use a bha exfoliant
with active salicylic acid
this is honestly the best treatment for
kp and as i said i'll add some good
options for in the video description of
everything that i'm talking about
always keep your skin hydrated never let
it get
dry because then it's just gonna get
worse use a good moisturizer creams are
better than lotions
develop a habit to always use a
moisturizer when you get out of the
shower
while your skin is still moist and then
try to use creams
with urea lactic acid or glycolic acid
[Music]
see your dermatologist they will likely
be able to help you with different
treatments treatments like chemical
peels
retinal creams and microderm abrasion
[Music]
humidifiers they're awesome because they
add moisture
to the air which will also help your
skin to stay moist
now if you want more tips on skin care
or grooming check out these videos here
and i'll see you there cheers guys